and there's people always backtrack on
their words so when i first saw the [ __ ]
out i always want to sit and challenge
just to see what happens right
so the first thing that came out from
people who said [ __ ] jacob blake he
deserved to die was
he had a gun right turns out when you
looked at the footage it wasn't a
[ __ ] gun it was like his cell phone
or some something else but it definitely
wasn't a gun yeah and so after they're
wrong and they find out that they're
wrong when this was the hill that they
chose to die on
and it was a [ __ ] gun they go oh well
it wasn't the gun but they did find this
no no let's talk about the fact that you
said it was a gun
yeah we can't glaze over that fact
because you already damned him to die
and said that he deserved to die because
you said that he was carrying a gun
you said that and now you're being
called out for it and now you're like
okay well he had a utility knife which
by the way a utility knife is absolutely
nothing
a utility knife in the side of his door
in
five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain
podcast we have the very talented
patrick t reilly here
and then we got the floor cookie eater
nick giarong for that one hey
you already know what it is baby cheetos
and crackers off the floor
y'all can send me cookies and my p.o box
but just make sure they touch the floor
first before we ship them out baby
damn guy currently
nick has a couple of podcasts that he's
on
the big mad podcast they upload once
every six years
and they also have the mma podcast with
gilbert the fat face happy birthday
gilbert
happy birthday to gilbert and then we
got alex the other fat face
y'all you guys you guys got the biggest
heads in the game in that podcast
bro i'm next wait till i blow my face
out bro oh i would love to see your face
blown out
your face already weird enough as it is
that you're going to be shaping and [ __ ]
you know sometimes when you watch
yourself on video and then like when i
turn my head because i never used to
sing that angle i'm like damn i got a
weird shaped ass head but yeah
yeah kind of like i think your head's
really tiny oh yeah dude
[ __ ] you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got him i
stood up for myself
who do witchcraft and they had that
weird little dangling severed head yeah
yeah
you right that voodoo head
yeah shrunken head yeah have you ever
been to a sidekick before
nah never kind of no never do you go you
go regularly
you guys say that like that's like an
occurrence that people do i feel like
well i don't know i've never been to a
psychic my grandfather in mexico claims
he could see the future
and he's like yeah yeah yeah so it's
it's just in the family you know
obviously i've been seeing those ones
he was like you have a blue aura around
you and i laughed and he was like i'm
not joking
and i was like okay oh yeah i know yeah
he told me i'd be rich like four years
ago i'm not rich so
yeah but it's blue aura it's on the way
up what's
it's just straight nonsense it's like
literally pure knives my mom's uh
special power is that she thinks that
what she dreams about
predicts the future although none of
them have ever came true
yeah and she's still till this day is
adamant that she can tell the future
so so she'll have consistent dreams that
something bad will happen and then she
has to call me immediately after it
happens
so for example uh last month it was that
she had a dream that i got into a major
car accident i was on the freeway
and a semi-truck ran into me and i flew
out the window and i died and she was at
my funeral so she told me
don't ever drive i'm like impossible
how the [ __ ] do i never drive she goes
don't drive for at least a month
i'm like you shut the [ __ ] up because of
my dream i know that once a month is
over you're good to go
yeah she goes after that you'll be okay
but she'll stay off the [ __ ] road but
but any part of you when she told you
that story did you feel like [ __ ] that's
kind of scary
well i think that after the first like
97 you were wrong
i was pretty confident it wasn't going
to happen anymore right right yeah she
keeps doing these stupid predictions
i have very weird women in my life and i
think that's the the thing that connects
me to the people that i enjoy is that
that weird quirk
and even marielle she her weird sleeping
habit is that she talks in her sleep
oh actually let me write down what she
said the other day i actually
wrote it surprisingly enough yeah i have
one of my favorites i like dream
journals i also have mariel journals
mariel's haikus in her sleep yeah so
this is what she said in the middle of
her sleep
that scared me and woke me up what the
[ __ ]
why are y'all pissing who keeps pissing
yo you gotta write that down yes because
of how odd it was yeah
and then i have a video clip of me
trying to wake her up and i go
who's pissing who's pissing me but she
wouldn't wake up
and she wouldn't answer she wouldn't
answer honestly a valid question though
yeah yeah yeah who's pissing
always pissing right so so what did you
what did she say when you told her about
it the next day she doesn't she doesn't
remember the dream but it's either
she's talking to the puppies because
they're pissing or somebody's pissing on
her
i don't know which one it is she's like
who's pissing kelly
yeah and also too the way that she said
it is not in her normal form of speaking
she goes
why the [ __ ] y'all pissing i'm like what
is this so why the [ __ ] y'all pissing
who keep pissing she hanging out with
david too much bro she's turning into
david
what the [ __ ] is y'all
[ __ ]
she's one of those personalities that
definitely she'll absorb
uh whatever's around her so like i i i
know
who she's around based on how she speaks
to me so for example her best friend
whenever she eats something good she
goes
mmm and now mariel has picked that up
so if i curse a lot meryl will start
cursing hey we should make her hang out
with alex for a while and then just see
what vernacular she picks up from alex
she'll be like that [ __ ] slap
magic mario doing that muriel just one
day i do something fun she goes ahaha
i will [ __ ] kill alex dude like you
ruined my fiance
we just gotta have her have him hang
around at the house i'm gonna blow up
his [ __ ] tiny car dude
[ __ ] out who's car smaller his or
mine well alex is the one that you could
drive around and not be embarrassed
ah that's true dude oh yeah hold on
check this out i have a story for you
guys
so after i went paddle boarding with joe
like last week
somebody left a little note
saying on my car is it cash for clunkers
yeah yeah where is it okay here it is
you saved it in your fanny pack you
[ __ ] where else am i gonna put it
you throw it away you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag i
need to have it just in case
for this podcast you can no not for the
podcast just case i want to call him
again
okay go ahead he goes if you want to
sell your sweet ass car
call blank let me see this let me see
that pass me the paper no no dude i'm
not going to destroy it i
absolutely will not trust me just don't
trust me
okay can you please pass this to david
please okay okay
this is a real note bro you [ __ ]
wrote this before you can
podcast this is your handwriting that is
not my handwriting this is your
handwriting
by the way it says it goes i fu is what
it says it doesn't even say if you i'm
not even lying it says
i f you so first of all he hates her
guts this guy [ __ ] me
[ __ ] we [ __ ] this he goes this guy [ __ ]
he was it's a stutter he goes i
[ __ ] you yeah yeah
this guy's good i [ __ ] you you want to
sell this car
call sal he was like hey
cole call me if you want to sell this
[ __ ] car when's the last time you
ever met a human being named sal you
definitely wrote this i've never met
sal in my life for real i still have a
coach his name was sal yeah
what's his full name sal distefano oh oh
that was so
what's he do uh meatball and spaghetti's
at night have a glass of water hey what
you're gonna do you're gonna meal prep a
pepperoni pizza that's right
and finish it off with a stromboli
that's legit as a guest bro i didn't do
that ask joe ask joe
next time he's here ask him if you wrote
that note it's a joke he's hooker [ __ ]
is not somebody that's credible at all
no or he is the most credible because he
is so honest
and he's a man that would do such things
like that okay let's
let's just say this how much would you
think that he would offer for your car
ten thousand dollars easier
10 g's 10 gs for your car with glycoma
how much do you think you get okay those
lights are damn boy
his [ __ ] lights are you know what's
so funny
the one thing i'd hate about that car
i'm like man these lights is yellow as
[ __ ] have you ever seen a a dog that's
like 16 years old
and they could barely see out of their
cloudy eyeballs that's what the
his head like my highlights have like
blood shot right on them for something
it's nuts how you i can't see [ __ ]
through that
you could high beam somebody and they
could look directly into your lights and
they'll be okay
sometimes when it's too if i'm driving
in the car with tips
the lights are on she's like are your
headlights on turn on your headlights
you'll get mad at me
but like they are on and i have to turn
on my high beams and then she'd be like
okay that looks better
why don't you just fix that you just got
to replace that [ __ ] that's like cause
i'm going to sell it to my boy cell dog
probably will hit up sal i'm gonna hit
him up salvatore when are you gonna sell
the car please let me know i'm just
trying to
figure out what i should do whether i
should just drive it into the dirt
or just sell it and then buy a new car
or lease something i don't know
what's your budget for a new car uh
that 2003 prius that i want is about
it's like it's like 2500 so i'm just
gonna just do that
yeah i want i only want to drive beaters
bro i don't want to drive anything nice
i just want to drive beater ass cars you
have a really really understanding
fiance
she loves me for ym she knows she knows
what i'm about
because i love the haunted element but
marielle hated that [ __ ] really she
absolutely
hates the miata well for sure i mean
she's a decent person
but you know what though i was i was you
know i was telling her i was like
she's like what get another car and i
was like i think i want to get a honda
element
because it fits my lifestyle you know
what i mean hon so here's the thing
about a honda element now this is just
an all serious thing if you do want to
get a honda element just know that you
will have to fix up a lot of things on
it
there's no honda element out there right
now so specifically
the um what do you call that thing the
[ __ ] thing that wrote the strut or
whatever [ __ ]
i thought that starts the stretch
is that the universal sign for an axle
your car can't even see at night
all right you know what's funny so on
the on the miata there's a there's
supposed to be a row bar and the row bar
is supposed to protect you when you when
your car flips over i love this so
the the the canvas top doesn't smash so
you don't get your head
chopped off pretty much my dad took out
the robar
to put in a subwoofer he'll be about
that life boy i love that dude that's
how you know your dad makes the right
shout out
shout out to john chinchou check out his
imd imdb
page that dude has some crazy [ __ ]
credits you know that
my dad worked on indiana jones i had no
idea that's crazy
yeah he was short around he was short
around oh yeah yeah
wow he was dating great he did great
yeah dude he's killing it sorry what
were we saying about the dumbass axle
get rid of that [ __ ] card yeah not
bro i need to get rid of that i had to
give her the honda element it was just
[ __ ] dining man
yeah well you had your catalytic
converter stolen so
that's a big deal yeah it was really
weird can i have that note back please i
need that
it's making me uncomfortable i'm going
to hold it
it said s c
t what the [ __ ] was he trying to write
yeah that's no word in the english
language
this guy's definitely a credible human
being bro it's a nice neighborhood i've
never held a piece of paper so soft in
my life it feels like [ __ ] toilet
paper
it is how long were you holding that
[ __ ] for like three weeks
call the guy and sell the car lately why
do too
if you want to sell your car or call
call sal
this is crazy bro i period [ __ ] you dog
i think i'm gonna back out of the sale
also
lower cases and capital okay
gonna kill your ass dude you're gonna
get raped stuff and you'd be somebody's
lamp in the living room dude
yeah there's some weirdos she's just a
sketch of [ __ ] he put i
hit him up he put right now
let's make the sale right now he's like
yeah
yeah what's up come over here you need
to make better life choices dude
he's a i think he's i think he's like
joe's neighbor so he's credible
joel's in a nice neighborhood uh dm me
if you guys want joe jacob's address i
will send it to you that is that is
hilarious
that is [ __ ] hilarious so i'm not
gonna we just found out before we shot
this podcast
dude chadwick [ __ ] bozeman all right
bro
passed away from colon cancer dude [ __ ]
isn't that [ __ ] nuts
talking about crazy black panther the
faux bloods
so awesome of a dude i am that makes me
so sad
20 20 sucks dick he was jackie robinson
i didn't know that
really he played jackie robinson he said
he was 42 or 43. so let's read it right
here so actor chadwick boseman
who played black icons jackie robinson
my man right here
film buff bang bang that's right and
james brown
before finding fame as the regal black
panther in the marvel cinematic universe
died friday
of cancer his representative said he was
43. damn dude
i thought that fool was in his 20s still
me too i thought he was just man
crack dude that [ __ ] looks great he
looks like he's 25.
what in the hell dude damn dude so
honestly that just sucks man let's like
what do you even say to that
i'm i'm a huge like i'm a huge like
marvel fan because i'm a [ __ ] nerd
i'm a nerd of all time
so this one this one makes me really sad
dude so bozeman died at his home in the
los angeles area with his wife and his
family by his side his
publicist nikki uh fioravante that's not
a real name
told the associated press bozeman was
diagnosed with colon cancer for four
[ __ ] years jesus it didn't tell
anybody nobody even knew
a true fighter chadwick preserved
through it all and brought you many of
the films you have come to love so much
his family said in the statement
for marshall to the five bloods august
wilson's ma
rainey's black bottom and several more
all were filmed during
and will film during and between
countless surgeries and chemotherapy
damn [ __ ] that's [ __ ] nuts he was
shooting films through chemotherapy
that's insane dude that's awful dude the
fact that nobody knew
until the day he passed away is [ __ ]
when i was looking it up i saw there was
like some people
like because he had lost weight i guess
and he like posted some stuff and people
were like why the [ __ ] did he lose
weight and someone
like there was an article that said like
oh he might be like preparing for a role
but like oh my god dude yeah that's
[ __ ] up that's
that's a tragedy 2020 what a year huh
what a year brother it's just like but
it's the thing it's like
it hits you when you don't even like
expect it this podcast is brought to you
by skillshare
are you that type of person that wants
to start or explore a passion
but you don't think you have the time or
maybe you don't even know where to start
that's where skillshare comes in
skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes to help you explore
new skills
and learn things on your own time and
schedule listen
there are a lot of things that i want to
do and learn and skillshare actually has
a dope amount of classes that i can
learn online
the classes are endless and if you're
someone like me that loves learning
things
on their own time this is what you
really do need to get
right now i'm actually doing a course
called filmmaking from home and the tips
that i use from it i actually still use
it in my videos
learning is such a process and everybody
learns on on their own pace and
honestly because they have such a huge
library i can pick and choose everything
that i want to learn and it's something
that i really enjoy
i feel a lot of the times people don't
like learning because they're not doing
it at their own pace and skillshare just
has these courses that you can pick and
choose from all the time and it's
something that i personally
really really do love so explore your
creativity and get two free months
of premium membership at
skillshare.combrain that's two whole
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free
get started and join today by heading to
skillshare.com brain
that's two free months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes at
skillshare.com
brain what it's like yeah you hear about
all this [ __ ] like
i remember like when when kobe died i
didn't think that [ __ ] was going to [ __ ]
me up that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up of course dude like
i didn't think i had that much of an
attachment to kobe bryant of course dude
you're a [ __ ]
toxic masculinity baby what else did you
go to your barbie house [ __ ]
did you cry [ __ ] let your heart scotch
your way to a [ __ ] tampon
yeah but not seriousness dude this sucks
it really does
but i [ __ ] that's the thing it's like
you don't even know what to say what do
you even say
i mean what
when somebody like this iconic dies
there are things that in my life i feel
i could do more to make more money right
but then i think those things that i do
wouldn't make me very happy so
i always think about what would happen
if i died tomorrow would i be happy with
everything that i've done the
relationships that i've made how i
behave what i've said
so it that's the thing where i feel like
for chadwick boseman he's passed away
but he's done more things in his life
as a 43 year old than most people even
aspire to have
oh yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah he
lived a great life i mean
like as far as lives go like he did
amazing [ __ ] he made stuff that's going
to be around forever as long as humans
exist you know
so [ __ ] uh yeah man i i mean we all
gotta go
eventually you know and at least he did
some dope [ __ ] before he went
it just sucks it just it just it's just
like death is the ultimate like
you're just like [ __ ] we're all like you
know somebody son
yeah dude so i know
somebody uh she right now is fighting i
think it's an aggressive either an
aggressive form of leukemia or some form
of cancer
yeah dude you want to talk about bad
luck right so actually uh
put out her go fund me for a hospital
building oh i remember this story right
so
she she found out whatever ailment that
she had
um very very serious she needed to get a
bone marrow transplant she's looking for
a lot of donors or whatever so they
found out this other way of helping her
out uh was through her brother who gave
her who donated blood or some [ __ ] or
platelets or something like that it
wasn't bone marrow per se that would
keep her alive and
she's going through all these forms of
chemotherapy so as she's going through
chemotherapy and by the way her sister
survived thyroid cancer so her sister
was a cancer survivor
she gets cancer next this is after she
adopted a child what the [ __ ] yeah so
she adopted this kid beautiful child by
the way
and she gets cancer and during the time
that she had cancer
she's going through like chemotherapy
and everything else right her pad passes
away
from getting swept away by a wave what
the [ __ ] so
him and his friends decided to you know
he wanted to go he was really sad
about his daughter's situation so and he
fishes a lot goes fishing
and he faces the other he's digging up
clams or
some type of crabs as bait but when
you're facing when you're next to the
by the way the ocean is a dangerous
thing
people if you don't understand if you
don't go swimming out in the ocean you
have to understand how powerful and
dangerous that [ __ ] is very beautiful
but that
that [ __ ] will [ __ ] kill you so
so they went into i think it was in the
bay area and they went to a very popular
fishing
spot but that fishing spot is known to
be a very dangerous place because the
waves are really strong
so he actually faced the other way as
he's digging up for these crabs but
while he wasn't looking a wave came
him took him and it filled up his like
the overalls those rubber overalls
filled it up with water and just dragged
him down oh damn he drowned to death
that might be one of the worst while
she's going through chemotherapy and
she just saw her dad her [ __ ] dad
dies after she just found out she has
cancer
yep and so uh that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks
yeah bro that's [ __ ] that sucks ass
and she's
and she still fought through it and
she's still alive right now and i think
she's
um she has to go through another set of
treatments but she has to do that
without seeing anybody because of kovid
so she's by herself for like jesus bro
god damn
that sucks ass i mean man
you just never [ __ ] know you just
never know dude does that make you feel
like such a [ __ ] though
can't cancer so like it's because my dad
had cancer he died from cancer but like
bro it's so drastic like it just it's so
agree because even if you get rid of it
like it just comes back in different
ways like once it's in you it like
morphs and finds like my dad had like
started with throw cancer then got lung
skin and lung again like it just keeps
coming i mean my dad didn't take care of
himself either like
he had smoked his whole life and like he
was like literally like i was trying to
get him to eat vegetables and [ __ ] and
he was like nah i'll just eat [ __ ]
donuts and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] i'm gonna go out like a
gangster and i was like bro he betcha i
remember we
my dad was so stubborn that like he just
if you he just didn't want to do what
the [ __ ] you told him to do
and so i was like i was telling him like
dude yeah like old school chicago man's
man construction worker
his whole life like blue collar as [ __ ]
and i was like trying to get him to eat
like these veggie shakes which i was
trying to explain to him like sugar
is bad for like it feeds cancer you know
and i was trying to get him to eat like
a veggie shake
and i was like come on like eat this
[ __ ] like it's good for you and he's
like vegetables are good for you he's
like says who
and i was like i was just shocked like
are you a [ __ ] mob are you arguing
against
vegetables like how do you even take the
stance though it says be like
[ __ ] vegetables my dad does that too
yeah but it was just he was just telling
me [ __ ] you i mean he knew he knew
he knew that obviously how the [ __ ] you
that's like saying puppies are not cute
like
yeah vegetables we all know vegetables
are good for you bro come on bro
it but i mean yeah i don't know it
it does make you appreciate life though
seeing all that [ __ ] i remember too he
had a
so he had a tracheotomy because like
that's like when they put the hole in
your neck because they had to take it's
like
it's uh throw it out or whatever um
and so at the hi of course like i'm not
a [ __ ] nurse or a doctor i don't have
any experience doing this [ __ ] so
everything's like crazy and new
and there would at the hospital like
after the surgery sometimes like mucus
gets stuck
in the tracheotomy in the in the in the
in the hole so you have to like suction
it out like the nurse and it's like
crazy for him because he feels like he
can't breathe but the nurses are calm
because they obviously they do this [ __ ]
they suction it out boom but when he got
sent home they gave us a machine and
they're like all right so just in case
this ever happens
you can do it right but now the nurses
have like
years of experience they know how to
treat them of course and also i'm this
dude's son so like the first time he's
like freaking out it's like the classic
like
you're working with your dad on a car
and he's just like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
the wretch the [ __ ] right i'm trying
to save his life but
calm down he's like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
and i'm like i wish i never had to be
like
he's like slapping my hands i'm like
stop let me get this
that's so especially i would i would get
it out but like [ __ ] it was a whole it
was a whole thing so did your dad
your dad had cancer because of smoking
yeah yeah he smoked his
i mean he didn't take care of himself
really like eating like nutritionally
anyways but like yeah he smoked like
he was at the in the age where like
smoking they thought it was like
vitamins and [ __ ] like doctors
oh [ __ ] when they would make uh pregnant
women smoking exactly so he he grew up
he was born in 54 so he grew up he
started smoking when he was like 13
like when they used to like smoking is
good business yeah
you know and it's like some dude with a
kid like so
which must have been crazy because
imagine like the middle schools back
then like
or like
so yeah he smoked for like his whole
life so
i should get that i feel like out of all
the stuff that's hyper addictive
obviously because there's a chemical
addiction to it
smoking is probably the hardest i've
known a lot of my friends who tried to
quit smoking and it's just an ongoing
cycle yeah they're offered for a year
they're back on for another six months
off again for two years back on another
it's just so hard like once they have
that addiction it's impossible to kick
all right that's yeah the whole family
smokes on my dad's side yeah and
the whole like you said constant oh i'm
gonna stop smoking
oh no i'm back on only for a little bit
only three packs a day
but they would constantly go through the
cycle of just like
smoking the whole time what took my dad
to stop smoking
was when he had a stroke yeah that's
when he was when he saw a [ __ ]
jesus christ when he saw a [ __ ] yeah
young god young jesus
no one talks about like how crazy like
you never hear about like i mean
everyone knows cigarettes are bad for
you but like they're still pumping out
cigarettes no one like is actively going
after that [ __ ] you know i wonder why
and also too like if you think about
like because like okay like
other drugs right like you have uh
cocaine they make cocaine it's addictive
because it is
the way that it is or whatever but like
cigarettes they literally
were like they they did like a science
fair project and we're like
how do we get the most addictive [ __ ] in
this to make [ __ ] get hooked
it's like the most evil
genius plan to like make [ __ ]
it's crazy but that's that's the crazy
thing it's like it makes them money
and people will always do what they will
do right and
people do the same thing scientists do
the same thing with doritos
like they're in a lab trying to figure
out the best bite of food that they can
give you
where you could over consume it and that
should that
should not be allowed for cigarettes or
doritos but that's the thing it's like
if somebody's somebody's gonna buy it
which there's a lot of people that would
be like
yep they're gonna buy it i'll buy
doritos you know because other people
unfortunately they won't be able to
handle their [ __ ] they're going to keep
over-consuming just say my [ __ ] name
i'm sitting right here
he's literally side-eyeing me right now
you [ __ ] face there's just some pieces
of [ __ ] hey
hey they're delicious no honestly that's
the thing it's like i eat doritos i eat
i eat crazy stupid dog he brings it back
to himself to deflect it because it's
true
but am i a better person than david yes
okay
okay no no no your car can't see but the
thing is like you can make something
taste good and [ __ ] are going
to eat like pizza
no there's nobody in the lab like yeah
how do we make the cheese the best
cheese
how are we going to make a pizza sauce
it's just a feta korean i come here
every day
but it's like dude just make this [ __ ]
taste good people are gonna come eat it
for sure once you get into the whole
weird like
how do we get them hooked up it's like
this is weird it's proven that they will
come back
it's guaranteed that [ __ ] are
going to buy your product well pizza is
good
pizza will never go out of style and i
don't think there's anybody in there
what if what is some [ __ ] ass pizza
would have what have you had this pizza
before and i was so
no i was angry i was in actually in cuba
i ate some [ __ ] pizza
i was like you're like okay cool bro
i was like livid i was pissed as [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] up like like like
like yeah it was like yeah like uncooked
terrible like
lunchables cheese but like [ __ ] 10
times worse than lunchable cheese
and also i thought it was salt and i
poured sugar on it it was it was sugar
so it was mostly the sugar no it was the
pizza first was like this is terrible
let's put some salt on it
sugar bit it almost [ __ ] [ __ ] my
pants right there
this is the worst [ __ ] ever had my
friend you want a pizza
what's up what's up what's pizza do you
[ __ ]
i served it to you bro it was bad and i
was drunk so it was like
usually that even when you were drunk i
was hammered and i
got mad like this is like i was pissed
why'd you go to cuba
uh just to go i wanted to go i want my
mom and my ex-girlfriend at the time oh
[ __ ] you brought the you about the woman
too
yeah terrible i was living with the girl
at the time so it was like
oh yeah i remember so much
and it was dope actually it was cool as
[ __ ] you never got into fights when you
went on vacation
um not on vacation no i i never
i don't think so it's about have i no
no never been in a fight on vacation
usually it's like a good time yeah i
never get into fights with mario on
vacation ever she's actually way more
relaxed on vacation she just kind of
chills and lets go yeah that makes sense
because everything is like about let's
just have this adventure
she found out early on when we travel
that i am somebody who's very unprepared
and i don't
care so she when we when we first went
on our first vacation together she had a
color-coded itinerary
and so she color-coded this itinerary
had all of her activities
like one day and so when she had these
activities and we we
went there and she was like okay we're
gonna do this and i looked at the event
i'm like
uh let's just chill out at this park and
just relax and let's just skip that
right she goes
well if you looked at the itinerary
earlier you would know that i spent time
and i put it on there
and now you're saying you don't want to
go and i'm like it's okay
i'm saying that it's a little packed so
let's just chill out this nice park and
we'll do the next thing after
she was like well you hate everything i
do i'm like okay
what is going on and so what she learned
early on is i'm very go with the flow
okay i don't care you know so as long as
i get to experience something during the
day
like two or three things if i didn't hit
six i'm okay
that's exhausting i'll come back and
what i told it too is when i go to a
country too
i don't want to see something just to
see it i want to experience it yeah so i
would rather hit us two
two locations really well then go to six
and just be there for a second and
bounce
yeah there's no point i can't remember
anything yeah it's hard too so now that
she's just kind of
she learned to be a little more um just
kind of let go
of things yeah so she learned early on
for example
she would freak out a lot if things
weren't going her way not
so much in a relationship but just
things in life in general so there's one
time we were i was supposed to drop her
off at the airport
to go to korea and there was a lot of
traffic on the way and she starts
freaking the [ __ ] out she goes well what
happened if i missed my flight blah blah
blah she starts getting super angry i
was like listen
you can be upset but you getting pissed
isn't gonna make this traffic go away
nope
we're already in the car we'll get there
when we get there
if there's a problem then then you'll
find out but we got there on time but i
said like
this this is not within your locus of
control right learn how to let this [ __ ]
go yeah there's a real [ __ ] point
because now i'm upset
you're upset and for what the result is
the same exactly we're either going to
be late or we're going to be on time
yeah why make this whole [ __ ] process
miserable
exactly but yeah i mean especially when
you're traveling like that's the whole
point is you
are supposed to let go it's like an
adventure like what i mean it's cool to
have like i want to see the eiffel tower
blah blah
but part of the cool part of traveling
is just getting into some weird [ __ ]
that you didn't think you were going to
get into
and that's usually like the best story
yeah like i drink a beer out of some
dude's shoe one time i don't know why
that happened but it was fun
i have herpes
yeah i was hammered in rome with the
with
my homie d and there was some dude
australians travel like crazy in europe
there's
everywhere they're like we're on holiday
southeast asia they rule southeast asia
but bro australians are the [ __ ]
i love i've never i've never met an
australian that i just didn't like him
that's true because they're just down to
like well let's just [ __ ] have a good
time
and they're just down with [ __ ] guys
they're like super chill they're just
like cool [ __ ] ass people like so
we're hammered in this bar everyone's
going crazy someone's passing a shoe
around
they're pouring beer and drinking out of
it it was like a business shoe no one in
the bar had a business shoe
a business [ __ ] type shoe on uh and
and i just drank it and i spilled some
on myself and some guy was so mad he was
like
that's not a [ __ ] good showing like
he got mad i was like oh my god
like [ __ ] off dude it's fine don't they
spit in the shoe too
i don't i don't know i didn't see no i
didn't did not if they did i didn't see
it yeah cause that's part of it right
bar situations are so weird because it
can either go
really well or really [ __ ] bad when
you have drinks with people that you
don't know
yeah it's crazy it's weird because
there's a certain moment where sometimes
people get too close into your space
yeah and then if you don't like that guy
then it's a problem it's a
problem dude dude i was in a bathroom
one time the same trip in europe where
in ibiza with the homie d
and there was a couple dudes like it's
just a normal guy bathroom situation
someone's washing hands
somebody got kind of close like was
pretending to like was started trying to
punk i think
my buddy d and like he was kind of like
in his face like that and and i
i know dee is down for whatever no
matter what country
yeah i'm like i'm like [ __ ] the wrong
like we're gonna find this goddamn
bathroom like
and then the guy like kind of backed up
he's like i'm just joking dog like like
but it's like why would you do that
but my buddy d kind of just like laughed
it off it was cool and then
somebody started like beatboxing like
dude like
and then somebody started doing the beat
to california love and then we all just
started saying california
california and everyone the dude in the
stall [ __ ] was singing
like everyone in unison and echo and
then like we got to the chorus it ended
and we're like
[ __ ] yeah and then we got we just left
that was in the bathroom that was in the
bathroom
that is [ __ ] hilarious and disgusting
at the same time
the guy in the bathroom was like
california that dude
damn [ __ ] american hip-hop goes
everywhere huh yeah and everybody knew
that the lyrics are [ __ ]
yeah everyone was so dope it was sick it
was like a really i left like happy like
man see
so you're right it could either be like
people stabbing each other or it could
be like these golden like utopia moments
where
that's how people should it's like the
lego movie like that's how people should
be living at all times there was
there was there was this dude uh there
was a bar
slash club slash lounge in sacramento
called
and i knew a dude that was a former gang
member
tight sick at the time he was still in
the gang
um he was in a hmong gang but this fool
is sad it's bad but it's funny at the
same time
huge brawl broke out in pallara we all
run out i don't know what's going on i
wasn't there with him i was with some
other people
and i see this fool coming out and his
hand has blood on it i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] happened he's like i just
[ __ ] shanked a couple of dudes in
there
and i'm like yo what was like what the
[ __ ] you know what he stabbed these
people with
what a [ __ ] fingernail clipper that
little thing that comes out
of the fight the filer and he just
started shanking people with this
little tiny thing wait he carried a
netflip around him i don't [ __ ] know
you can't make this [ __ ] up this full
stab
people with the the end part of the the
filer thing a little like yeah yeah yeah
and i was like did you stab somebody
with the filing of a nail clipper what's
wrong with you guys
disgusting that's terrible that was
gonna die from a bacterial infection
because for sure you were picking your
toes with that [ __ ]
yeah yeah who doesn't yeah that's what
it's for
yeah so bar situations are always i
always i used to hate it too when uh
some dude you don't [ __ ] know that's
kind of
within like somebody that knows somebody
within your group and they want to be
super chummy and they tied
so close that's my number one pet peeve
oh yeah
is with that with the people that get
really close to you when they talk
when you move away what do they do they
get even closer
closer and they keep walking forward and
they don't pick up the [ __ ] hint and
that is annoying and that's
disrespectful
and i don't like that at all hi
hi my name is nick but when i go yeah
yeah i'm running for office
uh when i go to a bars i get it i get
anxious i get anxiety
me too i don't like going when i go to
concerts i feel the same way too i don't
like being in groups so
and like tiffany is mad at me sometimes
because she's like yo like why are you
being like this
but it's just like i get really anxious
because i don't like when there's a lot
of people around me
and i don't know what they are who they
are
whatever and then i just for whatever
reason i just feel really anxious and i
don't feel comfortable i'm always like
do you deal with anxiety issues
i guess a certain point yeah with things
like that
but not really in other ways because
you're weak
yeah it is only weak people have anxiety
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's you
that's true that's sinking yeah
you know what weakness is a sign of a
[ __ ]
weak person oh wow that was good yeah
weakness is a sign of a [ __ ] weak
person i saw that a fortune cookie one
time
right so the top of a snapple cap
exactly
damn i forgot about that [ __ ] yeah 170
yeah yeah that was that was the
actual fact i actually deal with a lot
of anxiety myself i think a lot of
people where do you get anxiety from
what's your anxiety
uh i it's weird because number one i
actually have stage fright for somebody
to stand up which is very odd yeah like
i have a lot of stage fright
but do you feel do you get stage fright
before you go up i feel that's normal
right [ __ ] stage fright i also
get anxiety in large group settings
yeah same um i don't know i'm like
trying to figure out where i got that
[ __ ] from
also i get anxiety from like uh
let's say if i ordered something right
this is a weird thing if i order
something
and the product isn't the way that it
was described it [ __ ] gives me
anxiety
really yeah i don't know why so for
example when i moved to glendale
um i ordered a couple of things to fit
into that that podcast room right and
from the looks of it it didn't look like
it was going to fit
and i started getting an anxiety attack
and it's like an angry assessed anxiety
attack you know
i get some of that too yeah i'm like i
was like i ordered this [ __ ] cabinet
it doesn't [ __ ] fit in this [ __ ]
corner how the [ __ ] i should have got a
bigger [ __ ] apartment and then mariel
looks at me she's like
we're gonna go for a walk yeah right
you're gonna you know what else i get
anxiety from
when i have to assemble right before i
have to assemble an ikea
furniture because i know at some point
you're gonna miss something
yeah something something's gonna get
[ __ ] up i'm gonna get pissed
and then that's why you're getting like
but it's very lo it's very mild right
it's not like real anxiety but it's just
like
that feeling of like oh like for the
first time recently i actually bought
real furniture
and i found out that i forgot that real
furniture is already assembled
so let me open the box i was like cool
oh my god oh wow this is amazing
somebody did this all i have to do is
place it
you know so it makes sense yeah ikea
furniture
is cool but also is kind of annoying too
building it is a [ __ ] it's a pain in
the
building
it is a [ __ ] dude i hate that [ __ ] man
and it's always very
un sturdy a lot of the time but then
again there's something so loose there's
something
that's just this
what do you got against swedes i love
them they're great
no say what you want to say dude i don't
really know any swedish people yeah you
wouldn't you know why because you're a
bigot
yeah and i'm really trying to get this
guy canceled right now
from my circle of friends yeah that's
what i what do you have
what do you have against the cabinet
that donka fursaka fallen
didn't ever have [ __ ] i could pronounce
it yeah right like hey can i get that
cabinet please they're like what's it
called
frickasana finishes
yeah the serial number i don't know just
call it a bookcase yeah can i just what
about the bookcase guy no
say it would say i don't know what
you're talking about
i don't see that i've never seen
furniture with so much jays in it dude
just spit their food on the letters and
there's just dots everywhere yeah
yeah just krillin dots on all those yeah
so you know what dude
yeah i'm going to war with ikea and i
don't like sweets yeah like sweet no
yeah they're [ __ ] cool do you think
you think swedish people would even give
a [ __ ] if i was like yo [ __ ] swedish
sweets are cool as [ __ ] they'd be like
they're like so chill like my buddy
from sweden he says that everybody in
sweden just gets their furniture from
ikea they don't even know anything else
that's right yeah like ikea is just
that's just that's the place you get
furniture from
so anybody who hates on ikea they say
that's cheap [ __ ] your mom left you
facts facts facts and it was because of
you yeah bro
because you couldn't put that furniture
deal with that [ __ ] stupid in the topic
of 2020 sucking
we should talk about jacob blake
one of those weird situations too right
and so when i when i saw the whole jacob
blade thing i chose not to look at it
for a while because now i'll talk about
anxiety
when i see [ __ ] like that it gives me
[ __ ] anxiety i get mad you get upset
i get really really upset yeah and so
jacob blake and you know you guys could
go ahead and fact check your stuff and
we're at this point now
in this country where we don't even know
what facts are real at this point
because so many people like like the
posts you made right where so many
people
will take a small piece of the story and
extrapolate it
to fit their narrative of how they see
fit
very rarely do i see people when they
talk about these issues do they talk
about it as a whole
they just talk about it as jacob blake
being
whatever i don't know what the narrative
is but i could probably assume that
they're saying he had a criminal record
yeah he was doing something wrong yeah
like or whatever the [ __ ] like
you know he he or they're they're kind
of in a way
insinuating the fact that he probably
they're always they're always trying to
justify
death right and yeah how i want to say
this and this is like a
weird thing well this is why you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right you see somebody
die and the first thing that you say is
you don't think
man it sucks that this person got
murdered the first thing you think of is
i need to find the reason why that death
death was justifiable so i gotta find
out about this dude's rap sheet yeah
that is literally the most sickening
thing that you can do as a [ __ ] human
being
and that [ __ ] always pisses me off
because every time somebody gets shot or
they're killed
they go well ten years ago this guy was
this this and that
that was not evident during the crime
that happened so we have to talk about
the stuff that was present
at the [ __ ] moment right so and
there's people always backtrack on their
words so when i first saw this [ __ ] out
i always want to sit and challenge just
to see what happens right
so the first thing that came out from
people who said [ __ ] jacob blake he
deserved to die was he had a gun
right turns out when you look through
the footage it wasn't a [ __ ] gun it
was like his cell phone
or something else but it definitely
wasn't a gun yeah and so after they're
wrong and they find out that they're
wrong when this was the hill that they
chose to die on
that it was a [ __ ] gun they go oh
well it wasn't the gun but they did find
this no no let's talk about the fact
that you said it was a gun yeah we can't
glaze over that fact because you already
damned him to die
and said that he deserved to die because
you said that he was carrying a gun
you said that and now you're being
called out for it and now you're like
okay well
he had a utility knife which by the way
a utility knife is absolutely nothing
a utility knife in the side of his door
or his car right
they said that [ __ ] i think it was true
that he did have a utility knife and
they said that he was reaching for it to
attack a cop
when every single article out there
doesn't confirm it they said that there
was a utility knife but they don't know
if that's what he was reaching for
yeah that is what it says factually and
even somebody wrote on a comment they go
david i'm a big fan but you're wrong
he was actually reaching for a knife
blah blah blah and i looked up
everything i was like oh is this true i
looked up
every [ __ ] article i could find and
it said that he wasn't reaching for the
knife
that there was a knife there but they
don't know and and the and the police
will not confirm if he did or not so
that means they don't know
yeah so these are the [ __ ] facts here
so at the time what happens is that you
have a clear bias that you
want this guy to die and you're finding
anything that you can to make sure that
it's true yeah
what it what it's because what it's
become is it's like people's religion
now
especially like the more we move towards
atheism people don't have
a lot of people don't have as much faith
in religion anymore so they find these
new things
that like kind of become their religions
and for some people it's being a
republican or being a democrat or being
far right far left
being pro copying pro black lives matter
like people will
find their thing yeah and no matter what
like you you can hit him with the facts
you can hit him you can be like
show him a video and it's like it's a
piece of blue paper and if it doesn't
coincide with their story they're gonna
like that shit's not blue
like it's just be it's become religion
yeah and like i that's why i'm always
thinking like how the [ __ ] are we gonna
snap
out of it to the point where like some
reason and logic can come back into the
into the scene
and and we can kind of like figure some
[ __ ] out that's why i like for a lot of
things like
that video i was the same way i was like
[ __ ] man i already know this is
like it was going to bum me out and i
and people kind of
get it's easy to i think probably
because we're like
social animals like it's easy because
we've all been at concerts and [ __ ]
and like sometimes like the music isn't
that good but everyone's just feeling it
and you're like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] feeling
this [ __ ] too like whatever like this is
sick
right like i'm not a big baseball fan
but i remember i went to san francisco
and i had a dodgers hat i didn't even
i'm so not a baseballs fan that i didn't
even know dodgers in san francisco hated
each other
yeah and then people started talking
[ __ ] to me about my dodger hat and i was
like what the f i was like
and then i was like [ __ ] the giants and
like i literally don't care about
baseball but just because you're coming
at me i was like [ __ ] the giants you
know
so what's happening is like those people
that you're talking about
they're just so married to that side
whether it's the right side or the pro
cop side that like
there's literally i like i don't i
honestly don't know how to like get
through to people like that i don't even
know if it's worth it because it's like
it's like it's like trying to convince
somebody that's like devout uh
super [ __ ] crazy radical uh christian
that god isn't real like you're just not
gonna something has to happen in their
life for them to figure that out like i
can't it has to happen to them or a
family member of theirs
something yes somebody see that that's
what [ __ ] sucks is that
that has to happen to that degree for
them to think outside of themselves
yeah right and the other thing though
too is like the facts are so readily
available
everywhere with whatever topic you want
to think of the facts are out there
but people will continue to not do the
work
and not you don't have to get their
facts straight before they say these
crazy [ __ ] things i think it's
important sorry i'm sorry
no no that's that's all i was gonna say
but like to to like i think for people
that like
like what you're saying like where
obviously that that
the cops were wrong i think objectively
the cops were wrong in that situation
right yeah guys his back turned to you
there's four of you guys he's not right
he's walking somebody can just grab him
and take him down
didn't even try that you know like you
have four guys you can just get her like
a rear naked choke position you don't
have to choke him out but just get in
the position
do something tackle drag him to the
ground before he opens the door where's
your taser
he's walking like he wasn't running
so objectively they could have they i
personally think that they were wrong
right
um but i just i think that it
from the that position like that we
because we're rational here we know that
uh i think it's it's easy for us to get
sucked into those fights with those
people that are like
like you said uh but i think it's it we
do
better by like kind of just focusing it
on
on on i mean i guess it might sound
cheesy but like on the
on the things that should be happening
right like for sure this [ __ ]
yelling in your ear and you're like all
right but what we should be focused on
is police reform
yeah that guy wasn't upset or anything i
just kind of wrote back to him i was
like well when you find the article that
states that he was
that he was clearly reaching for that
knife instead of saying that the knife
was present you find that article you
write it he didn't write anything
yeah because it's not there so i think
he came to realization he goes oh i just
did
i just kind of filled in the blanks
myself yeah right and that you're you're
attaching um intention on somebody
that you don't know what the situation
was you're not there like
you can't do that because that's when
things get really dangerous
and there's other people who are saying
like oh the cop said that he was a sex
offender and that's why they were
that there was not a single article that
states that you had to go out of your
way look for this guy's
first and last name and find a criminal
record for you to even state that
so you're really really trying to find a
reason for this guy to be dead
but you know the other thing though too
it's like it doesn't really
matter it doesn't change the situation
that's what happens
say okay say he okay say he like he's
not a sex offender but just say for the
sake of argument he is
still it's the cop shouldn't shoot him
in the back
yeah right you arrest him he has his day
in court like that's how this process
works yeah you know i mean so even if
you want to damn him as the worst person
in the in the universe
the process is still [ __ ] up like he
shouldn't just be getting shot in the
back right there yeah so
it's like okay like you want to convince
me as a bad person
still what went down there was wrong
that's not the way protocol should be
going down
and there's just a lot of like hypocrisy
in this [ __ ] too right just because
and i think the thing that made me so
upset too was the was the young kid
who recently just murdered two people he
was a kid with the ar-15 he was 17 years
old
he glorified cops which is a fact by the
way it's on his facebook
he wanted to be a police officer
obviously this kid's a [ __ ] nut bag
yeah
because he has a semi audit he crossed
state lines to go to this place saying
that it was i didn't even i didn't even
somebody told me that he's not even from
wisconsin he's not he crossed state
lines which is already illegal
with an ar-15 he's 17 that's already
illegal nobody
nobody who's defending this kid wants to
talk about that they won't address it
right
and so he goes over there he says i'm
i'm here to protect
protect what this is not you're not here
from here jackass yeah right right so he
wanted to be
a superhero he in his mind he was a hero
yeah and he went there to go protect
whatever
property or whatever with this riot and
wanted to quell this thing that was
going on
because he wanted to be this this
dispraised well he was like he he was
radicalized i mean
it's the same thing as like a suicide
bomber being like i'm gonna blow this up
for allah or whatever the [ __ ] you know
what i mean like
it's these people that get like they're
so into the ideology that like
he probably thought what he was doing
was good he wanted to prove himself yeah
and is that at that age where he was
like
that's grandiose thinking yeah yeah i'm
gonna be a [ __ ] hero so
before anybody else who's pro this
what's this kid's name i forgot about i
don't know like kyle
rittenhouse or something yeah kyle
written tanner so
as we talk about this people won't
address that
you know what kyle's a [ __ ] kyle dude
that's a rapist
aaron kyle and karen's are [ __ ] yeah
so this so nobody will
ever address the stuff that we just said
and they'll go straight to this fact
right which i've seen it so many times
online now it's absolutely irritating
they go
well he was doing that in self-defense
because there was a mob that was
attacking him
right there was a mob that was attacking
him because he was there with a [ __ ]
semi-automatic rifle
exactly right he blasted somebody in the
[ __ ] head and that's when he got
chased with the guy with the handgun
and the other person with the skateboard
that hit him over the head so that guy
yeah so that guy lost his arm or
something i'm not sure if he got shot in
the arm
yeah so somebody got shot in the chest i
think it was the dude with the handgun
right but they only talk about that he
goes what would you do if you were
attacked by a mob
he shouldn't have had a semi-automatic
automatic rifle
he's 17 he shouldn't own it he shouldn't
have been there in the [ __ ] first
place
and he was looking for trouble there is
no way you have a semi-automatic rifle
you go into a right and you're not
looking for trouble that's the thing
it's like
you pull up you better be ready for that
smoke bro yeah
if you pull up to a place with a gun and
you're showing people that you have a
gun
you better be whatever your intention is
you better be ready for some crazy [ __ ]
yeah
and why would you well have all this
[ __ ]
if you weren't like you said looking for
some trouble it was his intention
exactly
it's not like they broke into his house
yeah and then he was like [ __ ] and
start shooting people and the funny
thing is as these people are
defending him right the police force
that you guys are talking about aren't
defending him
they're saying he's a [ __ ] nut bag
the police are saying
in that state that he's a trash bag and
it goes back to what the whole thing
about pat is just like what he was
saying
was about like people just want to
defend something because it's it's
part of their religion and it's like why
that's the other thing though too it's
people can't acknowledge the fact that
like it's either your team
[ __ ] jacob blake right or this
[ __ ] kid kyle that's what i've been
seeing like for my
because i haven't really been i honestly
for me when i look at the [ __ ]
i can only imagine what other people go
through but for me sometimes it's like i
can't even look at this right now yeah
you know and i have the luxury and the
privilege not to have to worry about
this [ __ ]
and then my doorstep right but the same
time it's like
i did look through comments i look
through stuff and i kind of breeze
through
but it seems that people want to either
side
this kid jacob blake and they make it to
this whole thing about how it's related
to this kid with the ar that pulled up
to in wisconsin yeah and you literally
can't say
what would you do in self-defense when
he showed up there with a semi-automatic
rifle exactly you can't you can't be
dismissive of that fact
you can't be dismissive that he murdered
two people right and there's like it was
in self-defense
well don't glaze over the fact that he
was there with a gun illegally looking
for [ __ ] trouble
exactly right i also saw there was some
other video clips of other guys
with ars i think they were in the same
town i'm not too sure
yeah but was there other people that
were pulling up they were defending like
a property but he was
roaming around with he was by himself he
was by himself that's the other thing
though too it was like
i was confused about that like why where
was and then cops were giving him water
bottles thanking him and all this other
[ __ ] i was like
yeah that was the other big issue that
people have with the police force which
they have to answer for as well
there's a video clip right if you if you
watch the whole clip in entirety and the
reason why people are using this defend
them they're saying that
well before he shot them there was there
was a mob that was attacking him and
i've already addressed why that [ __ ]
doesn't make any sense
um but as as as he's going towards the
cops and all these policemen and in
their cars
people are screaming yo he just murdered
people he just murdered people he walks
up with his hands up
and the cops just drive right by for
real don't even stop him he has a
semi-automatic rifle
isn't that like illegal yeah i'll put
the video clip i'll put the video clip
in the footage he's a 17 year old
with the with the weapon on him people
are screaming yo this guy just murdered
a couple of people
walks by the cops cops completely ignore
him to the point where he drives all the
way back home
[ __ ] nuts wait crazy he went all the
way back home he got arrested at his
house
wow back in his hometown what the [ __ ]
dude yeah
i'll show you i'll show you the clip of
him hands up as a guy screaming
yo that guy just murdered a couple of
people he murdered people
and he just goes up he's like giving
hand signals to the cops or some [ __ ]
has one gun on the [ __ ]
uh on one hand on his gun and he just
walks walks past the cops
we're doomed as a country so what do you
say to that what do you say to that
right he literally has a weapon he
murdered people people are screaming
that he's a murderer
and the cops go right [ __ ] by him you
have no explanation
if you say anything else besides that
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like objectively speaking right and we
we could even talk about this too
recently in pasadena
right there was a situation where a guy
he got a lot of people aren't talking
about it because it's very controversial
because
and we actually know somebody that knows
him i went to high school with him yeah
um grew up with him grew up with him and
everything well
in that situation it's a little tricky
and i think there's a reason why a lot
of people aren't coming in defense of
this
even though it's it's very terrible but
he had he had a gun on him and so when
he was running away from the
running away from the cop he got out of
the car and he reached for the gun
and he chucked it to get rid of the gun
well it's sad that he passed away
right yeah it's it's just a lot of
people i think a lot of people aren't
coming in defense to it because
as a cop you don't know what the
intention is when somebody reaches for a
gun
right they just see a gun yeah right
right and he got the cops
downed him right but obviously he was
reaching for something and it was a gun
yeah so those things are facts and
that's very evident yeah so in that type
of case i could look at that objectively
and say this situation [ __ ] sucks he
wasn't trying to use
the weapon in a lethal way but he made
the choice to get out the car
jet either because of whatever reason
that what it was and yeah he had a gun
they saw the gun a cop can't assess
whether he's going to use it to throw it
away or use it on them
it just it just sucks because a lot of
the times there's just so much going on
where it's hard to pinpoint
one person right yeah like it sucks
either way around like she
got shot probably not you know and it's
just like
i don't know well in situations like
that see like
it's more like rational people will look
at that and be like that's
[ __ ] shitty and unfortunate but you
understand where the cops are at
they have lives too they have families
they don't like you said they don't know
what if he's gonna turn and shoot
what he's gonna do you know so they they
have to they react in the moment that's
what it is what it is
but that's what's so crazy about this
other situation is that it's not that
you know
and and i think the people you have like
these extremes that are like always
either
far right far left but most people in
the middle
can can are logical and can can tell
like
okay that situation that you explained
it [ __ ] sucks ass
but it's understandable that the cops
shot right yeah we don't want that to
happen
obviously we don't want anything like
that ever to happen but in the heat of
the moment
you're you think your life's at risk he
has a gun boom you're gonna shoot he
made a decision and it sucks but
but we can all be like okay that sucks
but understandable but the other
situation it's like
nah dude that [ __ ] was not
understandable at all
those things are really dicey right so
like i i understand i'm trying to look
at it from an ejected point of view and
i'm also trying to look it from the view
of a cop
somebody reaches for something and it
turns out to be a gun which it was a gun
he just happened to toss it away that's
right i i'm not gonna sit there and say
well if i was a cop i would have
assessed it i don't know you don't know
i'm not a cop
but the fact that this dude felt so like
he was in a position where he was a
passenger
in a car that got pulled over for like a
routine traffic stop the fact that this
dude was probably so scared
that he he was gonna probably get shot
or killed because he had a gun on him
that he felt like he had to [ __ ] run
whatever whatever the case may be right
yeah i don't know what's going through
the kid's head
i don't know what's going through the
cop's head but apparently this dude
thought he was going to turn around and
pull a gun on him
yeah and that's why he shot right right
but it's
but that's the thing it's like you guys
have like people have to talk about
these situations because otherwise it
just becomes and you can't say
radical [ __ ] for example and cult was it
ann coulter whatever the [ __ ] that
little cutback name is she was like
i would somebody wrote um i want
kyle rittenhouse to run for something
and she goes oh well i actually want
kyle right now to be my president
shut up how do you write that [ __ ] who's
she said ann coulter said this and
coulter said that [ __ ] dude
no wonder nobody likes that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] stank [ __ ]
while you guys are while we talk about
ann coulter you guys should all watch
the
the comedy central road so they just
[ __ ] all over her
for like 40 minutes perfect very
sensitive
dude but that that's what sucks too is
that you have people that like
fire you exactly like they know they're
gonna make money off saying some crazy
[ __ ] like that's news bro and they've
literally like like that ann coulter is
like a like she's a hoe dude she's like
a [ __ ] like her she's literally
hoard her soul out for just these
reviews for views and money
she looks like the saddest person i've
ever literally will rather watch
the world burn for for for money
like like you're just like spencer
you're literally the definition of the
word a [ __ ] like
not even sex this has nothing to do with
sexual [ __ ] like it's just like she
literally sold herself out for views and
money
it's [ __ ] interesting you have a lot
of people like that especially in media
that
like that's they're feeding off of that
yeah
vote for
biden i was gonna say bernie i'll say
bernie we wish
i don't really talk about politics that
much because i don't know too much but
all i know is that trump can't become
president because i don't like the
rhetoric that he has
he lacks empathy and i don't want
somebody like that running this country
do you think he's going to win again
no not this is actually the first time i
feel very confident that trump is not
going to win what do you think
i think um i think he's going to win
again i don't think he's i don't
think he's going to win because he
dropped the ball a lot but i think it's
going to be more competitive than people
because
the thing is too is like remember this
narrative of like
how everyone would say oh like well you
know i don't like what the guy does
trump i don't like what [ __ ] he says but
like he's doing good for the economy
apparently like because i remember that
was like the number one i don't even
know if that's true
right now really especially uh right now
since it's definitely not true yeah
that's what i'm saying people are
you're right it is like a religion thing
they're gonna back their religion no
matter
[ __ ] what there isn't an outside
thought so when people say that stuff
right
i have a relative for example that talks
about this he goes well
um i think he talks about like how great
he's from i'll go
i ask him how he's like oh you know it's
just really general obscure facts
he's a businessman remember everyone was
saying that before he got elected as a
president they were like he's a
businessman he's going to do well for
the country
yeah these like there's no allegiances
to the to the
to all the rich people yeah right yeah
once my presence is going to grab a girl
by the [ __ ] i'm like first of all
terribly hilarious the fact that a
president would say that his [ __ ]
nuts
he kind of got away with it he didn't
get away with it he got
away with it so well it's like all those
[ __ ] are dirt bags and say crazy [ __ ]
like
they just don't get recorded trump might
be the most uncomfortable guy
ever i think the only person that
doesn't say that was obama for sure yeah
right i don't know too much about
obama's presidency i just thought it was
tight that we got a black president yeah
that was cool i know foreign
[Laughter]
what a great speaker obama is dude
michelle obama dropped the podcast i
love it dude
is it is it good michelle obama got
shoulders dude she looked like she could
hold the weight of the world on them
thank you she's in good shape
deltoids dog she's straight so she had
her she had like a dog
like she's got racial she had her older
brother on and he was like a star
basketball or football player but he was
talking about how
she was just as athletic as him because
her their father never allowed them to
do quote unquote traditional boy and
girl things
so if he was doing push-ups doing
sprints or whatever she was going to do
it too
so he always thought it was odd that she
never played sports like professionally
because she was that [ __ ] good damn
and you could tell by them big-ass
shoulders yeah i'm saying she looked
like a klingon dude
she got their necks and shoulders
their dad was very adamant that yo if
your brother's doing this you could do
it to even if you're a girl so she would
box with him she would do all this stuff
so michelle obama will [ __ ] you ass up
right right right well melania trump
looks like a [ __ ] robot
doesn't she look like she's like she's
like in get out like she just yeah
she's like stuck like she looks
miserable every day show me
show me videos of um trump trying to
like hold her hand and then he'll like
pull
like she'll pull away and [ __ ] she's
scared yeah i think she's like scared
she's like she's she's stuck she looks
like she's got ptsd for now she's
like stuck stuck she looks like she
hates her she like has her family and
like a bunker or something
like she's killed she's the only uh
first lady that you could actually find
real nudes of her
yeah that's crazy she was a she uh posed
for playboy you can see her titties like
look at it right now for um i'm about to
look up melania trump's dump the first
thing that's gonna pop
up is melania trump nude watch melania
trump
no way yeah you could look at her um
her reproductive organs wow whoa you see
everything oh i'm telling you i'm
frontal melania was a supermodel or
something okay
showcase you got
yeah dudes dude she was just covering up
her vagina dude wow that's crazy
there's like there's like different
pictures of her like
she's different ages in these pictures
like she's done it multiple times
she's she was a muslim crazy crazy but
look at this picture of her jesus christ
that's a crazy picture
i don't think that's her that's
definitely fake yeah but that is amazing
yeah that's somebody else that's a deep
fake
dude um that's this
present it's so crazy it's so crazy it's
like what is what's happening in the
past like four years
remember when he first became president
when they when he ran for presidency i
was like
that's hilarious he's gonna be president
yeah and he became president
i was shocked but the funny thing is
people don't even remember he didn't win
popular vote
no he didn't yeah which is weird which
that kind of really started
a huge distrust in the government
specifically in the people that i knew
they're like well why the [ __ ] should i
even vote
exactly well that and i'll talk about
when they [ __ ] bernie too
it was like another thing
because it was a problem with the vote
where because i guess for you to select
a certain candidate
you have to make a hole in the uh
flap and then some some some of them
like both of them were missing
for like al gore and george bush so
people wouldn't know
who the actual vote was for i don't know
man this country's going but
it's so crazy how in the past four years
everything is like slowly
like every all the rich people are
leaving everyone's leaving california
everyone's leaving the country they're
like yo [ __ ] this we're out
the covid is happening probably we the
us handled it
probably one of the worst ways ever you
know and our economy is [ __ ]
going to [ __ ] it's crazy dude i don't
know what's going on yeah
it's definitely crazy there's a civil
war about to break out in the us
going crazy just like the writing thing
like even the the riots it's so nuts
right now
just to see people so upset that they'll
destroy everything around in their own
city
yeah you know i i just we're watching
this stuff and i don't even know what's
going on and i feel like
specifically our youth you guys are so
poisoned sometimes with the [ __ ] that's
going on
you don't even know how to think for
yourself exactly like you will
say stuff tweet things post things
simply because it makes
you look like a good person not because
you believe it exactly yeah
that's a big problem that's a huge
problem i was talking about this with my
buddy edward cow it's it's really about
social currency and virtue signaling
it is you know everything is virtue
singular dude
uh jacob blake getting shot in the back
seven times is arguably i mean you could
even say that's worse than
um the george floyd situation where's
the black squares
where's the where's the post where's the
stories where's anything about that show
it's not around and i can't and it kind
of blows my mind where i'm thinking to
myself
we we we're
exactly that's why like i don't post it
like that because even if like i feel a
certain way about it i'm like
i don't like even the act of like
showing other people
that like i care about this like kind of
cheapens the whole experience i feel
that way i'm not saying that like
because
i feel like some people genuinely do
want to spread good knowledge and and
really care so i know there's people
like that
but for me personally like if i was
about to post something i
there's always it's just the voice in my
head yeah i was like why the [ __ ] you
doing this man you're doing this to look
like a good person you like
at least like part of like even if
there's like two percent of that i'm
like i can't i can't do it that's the
hard part i can't do it i'll talk about
this too where people were asking like
how come you don't do those those roasts
and those rants like number one it's
emotionally taxing yeah
number two and now it feels like i'm
just explaining it to get my views and
followers
that's the other thing though is yeah
it's weird it's a weird thing and that's
gross
yeah it just makes me feel terrible and
that's kind of a one of the shitty
things about social media that it's
produced is that
it's it's there's so much just phony
like fad looking like a cool person
jumping on these bandwagons
the other thing is too that people do
nowadays is like
for a while everybody was like [ __ ]
on kovid like they're not being real
they're like people are mad about covet
but what about sex
trafficking but it's like what that was
[ __ ]
why is it a competition that's the whole
thing it's like yeah it's
all [ __ ] up yeah it's all bad right
like why are you making it some like a
like the oppression olympics that we
were talking about yeah exactly or
people are talking about like
people will make comparisons to anything
like sorry it's so annoying bro it's so
but that's what it shows that their
mindset is based off
being a virtue signaler yeah rather than
really being about that life
some people just always just want to be
right too yeah they want to
quote-unquote like you said back their
religion they'll do anything they can to
do that rather than look back and
start doing that oh there's something
wrong did you see the video of like the
people at the restaurant like with the
like in that lady's face when they're
all raised all the white people were
yelling at this lady because they were
doing a black lives matter march
and everybody was putting a fist up and
they were like
they go up to a table so say you're just
eating at this table oh there's like
you're eating
and yeah like 60 people come up to her
table like this she's like kind of like
this
she's in her microphone like this yeah
yeah yeah like why aren't you raising
your hand
she's in pat's microphone like this this
is how close she is yeah like oh wow
yeah like they're in here they're like
what the [ __ ] and they're like telling
her like raise your hand she's wearing a
purple shirt you're like part of the
problem basically
they're like why are they yelling at her
because she wouldn't they wanted her to
raise her hand but also
in that group of people that were
protesting not a single color person
was there with them it was all i say
look look i know
i'm i'm i'm half white and [ __ ] but like
this the white
social justice warrior [ __ ] they
missed the mark are the most annoying
ones because it's like dude it's so
obvious what you're trying to do like
stop
stop it's i'm all about like if you
like if you think a cause is just
supported whatever but like you see the
ones that are trying like way too hard
it's like that's you [ __ ] are
probably the real races
yes exactly because it's like if you got
to try that hard like i don't have to
try to not
seem racist because i'm not [ __ ]
racist yeah you know what i mean like
i bet you those guys are like if you
like if you put a black dude in front of
them they're like what would you call
this person
they'd be like i forgot i'm a black
and it's like dude you guys are like you
they can't handle their own white guilt
so they have to like try to like
show everyone odd balance and
um one of my friends were talking about
this how
we need to find that good balance of
yeah like we want i guess
what what black americans in this
country want from their white
counterparts is to say like hey
you guys should recognize the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that you're doing that's kind of
caused like this generational [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yeah
but there's a balance of you can't
how should i say this they're not being
asked to be put on a pedestal
you have to be very careful in terms of
get them to recognize it
but you can't hate them so much to the
point where they'll just
lash back at you yeah cause there's a
point where you push somebody into a
corner so far they're not gonna feel bad
for what they've done they're gonna just
stick
stick in the ground even harder and say
[ __ ] you right and so
i i think because there's a lack of
empathy sometimes
on both sides that from from you know
because i'm obviously pro blm
i have to be very careful about like
okay am i
ostracizing somebody because they just
don't believe what i'm doing or there's
a way to do it yeah
am i lacking tact in this you know
especially when i have conversations
when i have conversations with people
which after
the george floyd situation i had
countless conversations with people that
were close to me about this stuff
but i didn't yell at them i didn't
scream at their faces they didn't
understand
we had an open conversation and we hoped
that we could walk away and learn
something from this
but i think in that situation with that
lady you're going into this restaurant
this lady doesn't know what's going on
and you're screaming at her
put up your [ __ ] fist i guarantee you
she's gonna walk away from that
situation and hate you even more and you
might push yourself
away yeah and also when you're doing
that like it's not even about the cause
anymore
it's just about getting people to comply
to what the [ __ ] you want them to comply
like it's literally not about the issue
anymore it's about you exerting power
over
it's [ __ ] that's exactly literally
you like me punking this person into
doing what the [ __ ] i want them to do
yeah and that's literally being a
[ __ ] bully and people
do this [ __ ] with everything with a lot
of [ __ ] yeah like
even in like like in fitness and
nutrition people do that
oh you're going you're going oh
carnivore diet wow like they'll do [ __ ]
like that
it's like bro we're talking about food
here bro yeah are you really gonna
are you really gonna dig your heels in
the sand and just make a stand about how
like your diet is so much better
like what than you talking about bro but
it's a way where they could be like oh
like i'm looking down on you
power thing it is that lady doing that
to the uh the blm protest where she's
yelling at the other chick in the face
she's putting her down like oh you don't
support this movement yeah right
you're a piece of [ __ ] but in reality
she didn't get time to think you just
yelled at her yeah she's like drinking
trying to eat spaghetti
you know time and place works for both
ways right yes everywhere everyone's
talking about time and place
specifically when people talk about
their own grievances when something huge
is happening right
like when people are like oh well uh you
know this
like you said like this stuff is
happening but across the world people
are starving time and place [ __ ] we're
dealing with this right now this is the
bigger issue this is the issue right
here but also that also works you can't
be a hypocrite about it you can't
walk into an establishment somebody's
eating their dinner having a good time
and screaming their face
put your [ __ ] fist up for blm right
and expect that person to
number one not be scared right number
two not to
we had this thing called normalcy bias
where we expect things to be certain
like the way that it's supposed to be
and when something comes in that's out
of
kind of comes out the side we don't know
what's going on we freeze that happens
when people get robbed when people when
something shocking happens and you just
freeze
that would happen to me too if i'm
having dinner and somebody comes in and
people are marching and screaming in my
face
i'm super pro blm but if you do that i
go uh uh
are you gonna get mad at me i don't know
what's going on yeah all right what is
this yeah exactly
but then what the main issue is is that
by her getting in your face all that
other [ __ ] doesn't matter whether you're
pro-blm or not doesn't matter
you're worrying about somebody in your
[ __ ] space during screaming at you
during covet while you're trying to
enjoy yourself because it's not about
it's not about that [ __ ] anymore it's
about you
enforcing what you think on me and that
is fighting words like we're gonna fight
absolutely if somebody did that to me
i would be very upset i'd be like yo get
the [ __ ] out of my table
right and then it will probably look
like i'm not against i'm i'm against blm
well that's definitely how they'll paint
it for sure exactly but it's like you're
starting to know you're in my [ __ ]
face get the [ __ ] out of here show some
goddamn respect yeah
you can be you can't pull up to somebody
like that yeah and expect nothing to
happen
so we should murder that lady that did
that
people are kind of losing losing their
[ __ ] minds and i i don't
it's not like i don't have empathy i
understand you know situations are high
they're watching their brothers and
sisters die out on the streets
but there has to be somebody out there
to say like hey you know you're yelling
at somebody it's during covid yeah that
person is going to be a little scared
there's a way to persuade someone well i
think we need to just be honest about
like
what what who's really about the cause
and who's doing it because they're just
being narcissistic and want to seem like
a good person
if we could differentiate i know a
couple and like people like that are
like super like like you know what i'm
talking about where they're like all
about like just trying to look like a
good person
and we could just be like yo [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] let's just
get to the facts let's like cool you're
spreading awareness whatnot but like
let's just be about this cause for reals
and any kind of bully [ __ ] like that
should be looked down upon like that's
not
that's not what this is about yeah like
this is about police reform like
it's about recognizing the the black
struggle in this country it is about
like all that [ __ ] that [ __ ] hurts the
car [ __ ] [ __ ] and not trying
to make this dude do this or do that or
trying to be better than like that a lot
of racism is ignorance too
a lot of like so when you when you meet
ignorance the
the solution is education it's letting
them talking to them communication
yeah sometimes you're never going to get
through to some people you're just not
or you might not get through
them right there but that's like if
we're like what's your goal
is your goal just to fight or make this
world a better place because if your
world if the goal is to make the world a
better place
you try to communicate with
[ __ ] it's like you said i know
it's hard
98 of people can't [ __ ] communicate
they say they're [ __ ] like
daryl davis guy right yeah he's the guy
that reformed
like a bunch of clan members and he
talked about how he would go do it
and it would literally just be like yo
i'm gonna hang out with you for a second
yeah these people are saying i hate you
because you're a black dude i hate
everything about you because you're
black yeah i got it but he's like hey
you want to get dinner with me
and what do they do they go all right
i'll talk to you you're going to pay for
it
which are black people dollars and he
goes like oh they're just regular
regular dollars but yeah yeah yeah i
didn't know
i thought y'all had different currency
and he goes oh actually we don't we
actually use the standard us currency
yeah especially if we're in the us so
you're telling me right now that you are
also a citizen just like me
uh yeah uh-huh and you're black yep yeah
yeah
really i play jazz music what kind of
food do you like uh
really anything i'm just whatever you
know you like mashed potatoes
yeah definitely i [ __ ] like mashed
potatoes too this is nuts
what about me i'm gonna rip you like i
just had meatloaf yesterday you get the
[ __ ] out of here black man
i know this great meatloaf and that's
exactly what happened and that's how he
stopped
racism but the main point is is that he
sat down and talked to them
and he came at them in a way where he
wasn't being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he wasn't being condescending he wasn't
putting these people down when you have
when he has every right
to put this person down man i had this
long conversation
uh to with uh with a friend of mine
about why
about why her doing blackface was wrong
and she didn't understand because for
her
perspective it was like well i'm not
racist i'm not doing disrespectful
things because i'm doing it as an art
form because i'm
dressing up as a certain black pop star
not art and so like face and heart
and so you know what i had explained to
her was you know that's fine i
understand your perspective we had like
an hour and a half conversation and i
told her like the the one thing that
you're being very dismissive of and
you're kind of ignoring
is this country's history you can't do
that while simultaneously ignoring this
country's history and not expecting
people to be angry at you right
right i was like for example if if
because you know we're both korean like
if
somebody who wasn't from korea came over
there and just started talking about how
japan is better than korea
and they're labeling all these facts but
they're not talking about and they're
like okay well i'm just saying stuff
that i've learned
but and they're mad at somebody else who
are being offended by that but they're
not accepting the history
that japan just raped our whole country
they would you would think that they're
an [ __ ] and she goes okay i
understand that too
and how i also broke it down to her this
and this took an hour and a half
yeah like i didn't want to have this
hour and a half conversation but i sure
as [ __ ] wasn't going to sit there and
yell at her yeah right
because she wasn't coming at me hard
sure so i wasn't going to come at her
heart so basically at the end of the day
what
she was like i think she kind of
understood and she still doesn't
understand that she's still doing black
face of this day right
yeah she did it the next day see
david she went through a black face she
taped her eyes all day yeah and so what
i told her too
was at the end of the day you can't be
dismissive of the history and she goes
well i have
a black friend i was like well listen a
lot of people say black friends i was
like but let me just tell you this right
now when you when you sent that
group photo to to your bunch of friends
right and then there was one person that
was very upset about it right
she goes they weren't black you know i
was like but you had your one black
friend that did that
and within your little group however let
me just put this scenario for you
number one if i went to your whole photo
album of your life
how many black people would i find
around you i was like probably not that
many
so what is your perspective of black
culture when you didn't even grow up
with the culture number two
if in fact if if you sent that group
photo
to a different group and they were all
black people would you have sent that
photo in
probably not so in your hearts of hearts
you know that it was wrong
but you felt comfortable doing it in a
group that you know that most people
wouldn't speak up
that one person didn't and that person
was the odd person out and they said
that they were very uncomfortable
with this even though you said it in
this in this performance i was like you
cannot be dismissive of this country's
history and it'd be upset that people
are upset at stuff that you choose not
to understand yeah
yeah yeah and yeah and and that's that's
a gift
being able to communicate like that as a
gift and also taking the time to do that
it's like a conscious decision
and you're right you mentioned it
earlier that a lot of people don't know
how to communicate they
they just can't but you just just try
like if either
ignore it or try your best like just
strive to communicate as best you can
you know but i mean i know for a lot of
people it's tough but
that jesus christ thing is [ __ ]
difficult man like just sitting let's
break bread
because sometimes i'm trying to go full
satan on somebody yeah you want to
murder somebody you want to bring their
[ __ ] neck
and also it's like whenever you try to
do something like say
blackface that's not very popular right
um
don't use the crazy bro don't don't
worry don't ever
don't use the justification saying oh
it's art
i have a black friend yeah we gotta use
that like i have a friend i think
everyone knows that that's a pretty
shitty
i know but i i hear it but but people
still say they still do they still
do it dude yeah yeah so for instance i
have a i have somebody that i know
he likes making asian jokes he's not
asian right
he makes asian jokes on social media
whatever that's fine i don't really care
yeah i can give two shits right somebody
that i know
went up to him and was like yo yo why
are you saying all this stupid [ __ ] like
shut the [ __ ] up
watch what the [ __ ] you say and they
always go well my wife is
asian don't give a [ __ ] does it matter
dude it doesn't matter if somebody is
saying hey man
this bothers me that you're saying this
like i don't know what why is it so hard
for you to say
oh my bad i'm sorry bro yeah what is
your wife why is it so
hard for people to say that to the point
where they have to bring something up
that's so
irrelevant oh my wife is chinese yeah i
enjoy an orange from time to time
that doesn't apply to the conversation
that i'm having also was a joke even
that funny
no not exactly fine and that's terrible
like i've laughed that asian jokes that
non-asian people made and that [ __ ] made
me die
[ __ ] laughing you know i'm like that
[ __ ] hurt but [ __ ]
it made me laugh more than i cried so
i'll take it but that's the thing it's
like
who gives a [ __ ] right it's like just
just take your l bro
it's not that big of a deal but that's
what's good too about like comedy in
general like in comedians it's kind of
it's it's good for society that we're
not healthy because
like that well that we don't get really
offended by most things because like
you have to um we can that's why we can
detach and have these conversations
that's
you might feel us some type of way about
something but like because we're comics
and like if
we're always striving for like what's
the funniest [ __ ] it doesn't matter like
what's
funny is the the metric right um that we
can
take chances and uh if you if you bomb
and [ __ ] up it's not funny it's like
[ __ ] that it was like that sucks but
like
your intention still was funny um but
it's like
that's the role of the comedian in
society is to try to i'm not saying this
guy was that but
like to try to like he's very take the
chances
to like push the conversation in realms
that people aren't comfortable i'll give
a great example too and this
also has to do with rapport right there
was this other buddy of mine in
sacramento who was a comic he was black
dude
right and he made like an asian joke at
me he was like oh david got a small
[ __ ] dick when he goes to a urinal he
doesn't know where the piss comes from
right that [ __ ] made me die laughing
right i was like trying not to
relate to that and i wasn't looking at
him so i had to do it was like he's like
you ain't gonna say [ __ ] i was like i
don't even know you were here you just
look like a [ __ ] shadow with teeth
you know so he made an asian joke i made
a blackjack right yeah
so like we would just roast each other
and that was fine and we both cracked
the [ __ ] up
personally i thought his joke was better
that should make me die later that's a
good joke he literally said my piss
would come out of nowhere like a magic
trick
i died last night i feel like you
laughed david i feel like you get credit
for how fast you came back to that yeah
it came super fast because you know
people had had those jokes for me all
day growing up yeah so i kind of come
quick and i was lucky that [ __ ]
was precious purple dark
oh that [ __ ] was dark as [ __ ]
yeah yeah stand next to it my mother was
standing with brick wall he looked like
an alleyway
right and so you know we would roast
each other about that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we used to just clown on each other like
that all the time but we had rapport but
that's fair
you guys knew each other and it was
[ __ ] funny what he said and this [ __ ]
made me die laughing i wasn't gonna not
laugh at that [ __ ] yeah and it was hard
for me to resist because that [ __ ] came
out of nowhere i was like that's a funny
small dick joke dude
and that's always fun when you have that
rapport with somebody and you and your
whole
relationship is you guys just saying the
most kind of like racist [ __ ] you can to
each other yeah but making it funny
yeah yeah you're verbally spawning
that's the best that's that's so fun
yeah absolutely doesn't mean all the
time but i have no comebacks for him
he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'd be like once you
eat some twizzlers you stupid [ __ ]
depression candy [ __ ] yeah with your
old ass
[ __ ] up charleston chooses the [ __ ]
charleston chew
chopsticks i'm gonna get some apples bro
charleston
1900 sexual harassment moved in you did
the charleston chew on her
cincinnati bowtie hey mickey do the
charleston chihuahua what did she say
she was like yapazaba
so she was into it yeah wow cause that's
what that means
yeah r.i.p to chadwick dude yeah man
well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
hope you guys waba zap it from this
happen baby
yeah make sure that you guys follow dot
riley when stand-up comes back
[ __ ] be hitting that stage
bringing the giggles to the [ __ ]
yeah your [ __ ] y'all just wait
all right [ __ ] we might even do a
stand-up tour next to you don't you
[ __ ] know
i'm putting out in the ether hell yeah
that'd be dope as [ __ ] that's right i
got a bunch of covet jokes that's gonna
be completely irrelevant next year
and then you can follow nick at nick the
ear if you guys are looking for
fitness [ __ ] my man is helping people
lose weight and get their life right
what's up hit me up if you guys have any
nutrition or whatever questions
nick the ear baby i've gained 30 pounds
while working with him
um goal